our series pushing the limits shares
stories of ordinary people who are
accomplishing incredible feats this
morning we're going to take you to the
mariana trench in the western pacific
ocean the deepest place in any ocean on
earth in fact if you were to put mount
everest at its bottom the top of that
famous peak would still be more than a
mile beneath the ocean service
also pronounced surface crazy
cbs sunday morning correspondent that's
lee cowan brings us the story not about
a place but about a woman who conquered
all the odds to explore it we like this
she made history along the way
in the waters of the western pacific
where the color blue was seemingly born
oceanographer dawn wright
was a little blue herself
my mother she died in december she
wanted to be able to to live to to see
this but she is watching from from
heaven
the next morning wright a specialist in
marine geology and geography at the
environmental systems research institute
would take on the challenge of the
deepest place on earth i'm actually the
first person of any gender of african
descent to to go to challenger deep no
other black person has gone to
challenger deep
challenger deep
seven miles beneath the surface more
than six times deeper than the grand
canyon almost triple the depth of the
titanic
it's been seen
by so few
sinking that far down isn't the problem
of course it's getting back without
being crushed that's the conundrum and
currently there's only one manned
vehicle in the world that could do it
coming out it's called limiting factor a
two-person submersible that's the
brainchild of texas adventurer and
explorer victor viscova
thank you
he personally financed its design and
construction
if it can work here it can work anywhere
on the seafloor the trenches in our
ocean are largely a watery black hole in
terms of research but these hard to
reach places do have so much to tell us
the earth's reaction to climate change
for example how we can better predict
earthquakes and tsunamis
perhaps
even how life began it's very cool
wright's task will be to bring back the
first high-resolution mapping of this
unforgiving place
how much of the ocean is mapped
currently the current number is 23.4
percent
of the global sea floor not even a
quarter is mapped
to sufficient detail last year the un
pledged to change that setting a goal to
have at least 80 percent of the seabed
mapped by 2030
but one of the best tools to do that is
sidescan sonar and historically there's
always been one big problem that
environment is so harsh
that these sensitive instruments
typically can't survive it but we think
we've developed a technology to make
that happen
the only way to know
is to go okay there is a necessary
claustrophobic element to any deep dive
wright has been sardined into subs so
many times that she's even got a
nickname
deep sea dog
but this trip is different
even for deep sea dawn this is
extraordinarily dude she'll be passing
through more than four times the deepest
she's ever been before and when she gets
to the bottom of challenger deep
she'll be experiencing more than a
hundred thousand tons of pressure on the
outside of that submersible
surface this is the lf the hatch is
secure the life support is running i
have a green board i'll get in here
soon the ocean consumed them as if they
were swallowed whole
wright's love of the ocean started in
her home in maui
where the waves appeared every bit as
welcoming as the sea of stars above
when did you want to be an oceanographer
you think when did you really want to uh
it was at the age of eight
because it was partly fueled by the
apollo 11 mission if those men
could
land on the moon
i thought well why can't i go the
opposite direction and explore the
oceans but back in the 70s and 80s there
weren't many oceanographers who were
women
fewer still
were black
were there obstacles when you were
coming up when you were growing up all
kinds of obstacles i spent several years
at sea as a marine technician and they
were
men on the ship that i was on who didn't
believe that that women should be there
that is a story an age-old story it is
still an issue
all of that though was about to be
eclipsed by her arrival at a place void
of judgment and prejudice
that's the bottom of the ocean dawn
there it is
out of the gloom
there it was
[Music]
surface
lf depth one zero nine zero four at the
bottom yeah
all right
congratulations
wow what an image down there thank you
thank you victor
every second at the bottom was revealing
almost too revealing what is that
that is artificial
humans themselves may be foreign to this
landscape but
sadly our trash is not to bomb it's a
freaking bomb that's something it's a
bottle as soon as we get here
not as pure an experience as she'd hoped
for perhaps but
her disappointment soon turned to
excitement oh look at this that first of
its kind side-scan sonar so many feared
would give way under the ocean's
unrelenting pressure
hummed along as if it was mapping a
shallow lake those are interesting
features
most explorers will tell you that there
is one constant about pushing the
envelope dropping surface weight
ascending
and that's that there's never enough
time
[Music]
after 10 hours beneath the land of
sunlight air lungs
deep sea dawn resurfaced
returning to the pitching deck of her
research vessel where the real work of
analyzing her research
had now only just begun
that smile on dawn wright's face however
was all for her mom to always encouraged
her to chase her lofty dreams
even if they lay
at the bottom of the world what do you
think your mom would think
i think my mom would be extremely
relieved
[Laughter]
somewhere high over the deepest spot on
earth
i'm like
for cbs mornings
bravo wow
she's different than most black women i
know because we don't like to get our
hair wet that's so much time so bravo to
you and the work that she's doing y'all
think about getting her hair right this
is the real girl i thought you know
that's true now that's true i don't have
a wife i'd be sitting on the side of the
pool yeah this is the real girl when you
asked her earlier like do you like
having fun outside and you said yes i
knew no you know i do i do i like hiking
i actually outside on the balcony on the
terrace i do like hiking
i